hey guys welcome back to another episode
of awesome bill
so this NC is gem in the Holograms
so as usual I got my list we have closed
for Doug a wig makeup to make him look
like gem close for Malcolm and Tamara
look like gems backup singers makeup for
either a pencil going to Malcolm's eye
or a pen or any other extremely violent
thing that we can do to them so that'll
be interesting so a bowler hat take my
stache and a monocle for Malcolm I think
we have everything but the monocle that
I can kind of probably whip up and let's
see if it's in your time and power to
make a synergy puppet just something
that I can hold up from below and shake
that could possibly be a fun build but I
understand if you're too busy with other
stuff
I can always just use it cut out the
wheel is not needed if you decide to
make it so I'm probably gonna make it
I've seen a picture of the thing it's a
couple of balls basically without light
in the head and a wheel at the bottom
whatever and if I don't even use the
wheel I can just basically find a couple
of or objects plastic and glue them
together and paint them and well the
interesting part it's gonna be we got to
stay up Malcolm in the eye with a pen or
pencil a pen is more interesting to me a
dog when he first told me that he wanted
to do something like this he recommended
it you're like getting stabbed in the
eye and I thought there's something else
interesting we could probably do but
then I came up with a kind of a cool
idea
for the eye if we use a pen Doug would
be a lot of blood gushing and stuff like
that so I thought it'd be fun idea of
when nothing we'd stabbed in the eye you
see the pan and while he's talking to
Doug the little the end of the pen pops
off or the cap pops off and blood
squirts out of the actual pen in order
to do that I'm gonna have to build a
latex prosthetic the goal cover-up
Malcolm's existing eye and we'll have to
run tubing that we can pump blood
through so I'll get a pen just a cheap
pen and some clay I'll make a prosthetic
we'll make a mold I'll pour some latex
into it and then we'll pull it out and
connect the tubing and stuff like that
so that we can pump out the blood and
stuff and yeah it should be interesting
I'm sure I have enough stuff lying
around here or I can make something so
yeah let's get to it
all right so we're gonna sculpt the eye
out of sculpey say modeling clay pretty
common you find it at just about any
hobby shop or art supply store saves it
to sculpt maquettes
or prosthetics and stuff like that or
appliances and stuff so yeah just gonna
take a little bit of sculpey we're gonna
sculpt it out I'll get a piece of poster
board or something like that that I can
sculpt on the surface and then I will
build a little box around it or get a
cup or something like that and cut it
off and glue it on there and we'll make
a mold using some plaster of Paris I'll
mix up real quick
pour it in there the mold should cure in
about an hour we'll pull out the clay
and then we'll have our prosthetic eye
so yeah let's get to it
well the latex is curing I've got a lot
of time it's gonna take a little bit for
that to cure up let's build the Sanji
puppet so I found some this plastic
sphere ball tena thing that we used for
the thing goes for the Star Wars Episode
I remember what exactly it did but I
remember getting it for that but oh yeah
I think that'll be cool I can put a
light net even and painted white it
looks like in the picture that Doug sent
me it looks like it's white and gray and
then this egg plastic egg I'll just cut
the top off of it maybe cut out some
pieces or something put the head on it
paint this I don't know I had some
little little nuances to it or whatever
maybe using some other reflective tape
and that'll be it that'll be the puppet
so I think it'll look enough like it
producted tell the joke so that's it
we're just gonna start throwing some
pieces of plastic together
all right so here's the puppet didn't
turn out that great partly because the
paint is starting to rub off on the the
or but the the plastic ball I had
initially had a coat of metallic on it
and for some reason half of the white
paint adhered to it and half didn't so I
got all smudged up so I just trying to
wipe off as much as I could
I'll try and put another coat on it
overnight and see if it takes most
likely though it won't so hopefully it's
still good enough for Doug for tomorrow
it pops open turn down a little white
and then you can still kind of use it as
a puppet so again I didn't have to add
the wheel only spy just gonna hold it
from like underneath and do some stuff
like this so but considering it's
probably gonna be only on screen for a
few seconds I think it'll be enough to
kind of tell the joke so let's see how
that mold is doing the latex hopefully
is cured by now we can pull it out of
the mold and see what it looks like if
it's gonna work hopefully it works cuz I
don't have enough time to do another one
so let's see
you
all right so as you can see the HR not
pretty good apply it like this
kind of something in a little bit paint
it up and yeah I'm gonna do a little pre
coloring I'm gonna make get some makeup
and darken it up and try and get it so
the least amount of stuff that I have to
do tomorrow on set the better it is
gonna take a while to apply this to his
face and everything and blend it in but
one trick that I've been using as of
late has been using men's grooming tape
- it's basically a double-sided tape
that airs to the skin really well it's
actually it's called grooming tape but
it's basically like for men to keep
their to payza it works great for
applying latex pieces in a hurry spirit
gum sometimes takes a little bit of time
and depending on the situation a lot of
times we get I have to apply this stuff
really quickly so that we can film
everything in a day and everybody out at
a reasonable time so the grooming tape
works great because I can put that on
like a double sided tape put the
appliance in place and then blend it in
with some added latex blow-dry it and
start applying the makeup to blend it in
what do you my Dave who's does sound
stuff first once in a while he uses it
for labs and stuff like that and you
recommended a teasing this is great in
fact he gave me a box of stuff and I use
it all the time for this kind of stuff
so once again thanks Dave this hose with
the elbow on it will go in there like
that I don't they put like a backing on
this to keep it rigid all the glue it
all together so that the piece isn't
loose inside there
I'll kind of go behind outcomes here
we'll glue it into place
add the make up and hide it and then the
pen will attach to this so plastic
sticking out and when it comes time for
the blood I'll be at the other end hose
with a syringe full of blood they will
go pump and it should go up yeah in
theory so we'll see how a customer
like all right so Falcon famous in the
live here yep so what you're saying the
behind the scenes you show your yes I
kind of went over i sculpted it and how
I made the mold and everything and
painted it and now we're applying spurt
gonna take four days to come off so you
can live with it now careful mouth on
the side effects is blindness
sister-sister I had a feeling
aside from that did feel thing
definitely like a Mia like yeah me right
now is Jenkins stuff look at that blood
coming out of his ears and nose and
mouth too
did you want any picture too it's um
it's growing in graduate I did shave it
once in between that's India indeed do
you know this means the pen is mightier
than the sword
Henry Henry do you cover the tubes I
mean if not I mean do what's gonna save
it maybe with the glasses I mean we
could just take out one of the lenses
yeah I think yeah we'll try it out but I
think it's gonna it's gonna cover that
it would look so much cooler if the
glasses weren't there
yeah no I mean that's I agree
this is so cool then we do our horror
movie I'm gonna get all sorts of horror
door shit door door door
poor door okay do you keep up with in
stuff I have not watched any of it so if
you guys want oh it was convoluted dead
center you haven't even seen it time
travel no I read about it yeah
Hodor is involved in time trout was on
the internet in seconds writing in
forever so we're blending in the side a
little bit more most part blends in
pretty good yeah so we're gonna add some
more blood especially I camera that
should blend pretty well yeah lots of
gore in the show yes this is it I was
wishing there was some engine on the
hologram
then get one point we had somebody had
an eyeball come out yeah I'm in the no
chick-flick actually mama be here right
oh yeah there's like so much estrogen I
just have to do something like
testosterone door did you after they
keep smiling trav like is there like
like do that yeah they're actually
walking away you know say you're ready
cooling tonight you know and they pretty
much as soon as I saved that why you can
have one folks flirting Yavin they'll be
dancing away now here's the thing that
is even with him walking away
and then we should get him to a hospital
yeah that's crappy and that is what the
blood is Jimmy is they like and we're
gonna farm we slaughter the fatted calf
Apocalypse Now Styles is it just blood
from like a a store yeah it's just
Halloween store blood like I would say
test them out at a Halloween store
because they
are some there's some incredible ones
and there's some bad ones yeah there
were just put a little dab on your hand
nope doesn't hurt no it's padded so I
was good well we have to fill the tube
with our first yeah again only hurts
when I think about it feels like my eye
still there yeah it's just a pen now pin
I let me know what helped you ever spin
off two pencil head yeah and I pin eye
for the quill guy how are you
yeah oh is that just the edge of the pen
or that okay that's gonna splurt out
when you push the water hi guys oh that
would be finished by you cool yeah I'll
be mean bearberry so right up you see
you're lying I'm gonna push the plunger
okay plungers now cuz it go straight up
good dad okay now let's do you remember
how you sit the like the last time cuz
that's just repeat that as fish again I
actually hate gym before you do that do
you want to add a little bit more blood
on the side of his eye to blend it a bit
more sure I can see it's starting to
wear up a little bit and this is the
money shot sort of the money
I'll not come show me where you're gonna
be looking right there about there yeah
okay so I shouldn't have the camera okay
so again just to make sure we have the
lines down I'll do the weight like a
second and then say we should probably
get into the hospital I could literally
have seconds yeah we should probably get
him to the hospital
I mean okay okay all right all right you
ready Jim yeah this is the real one
yep okay all right grand on the set
ready Malcolm great amber mm-hmm and
we should probably get him to a hospital
I may literally have seconds